Iran's president has announced that
poorer people will start receiving
subsidies on Monday to help pay for fuel
price rises it's Hudson rouhani's
response to protests against the
increases Iran's president of course
announcing that those subsidies will
start on Monday now we're going to go to
dr. Rob Jabari now who has more on this
from Tehran president Hassan rouhani has
been making a few comments following his
weekly cabinet meeting on Sunday evening
in the capital he said that it is the
right of every Iranian to protest that
it is not their right to cause riots
he's referring to over a thousand people
that have been arrested over the past 48
hours as a result of a number of
incidents that have taken place over all
over the country in number of cities
over 87,000 people have turned up to
demonstrate and show their frustration
at the news that the price of fuel has
tripled overnight the government made
this announcement and the president was
defending the government's decision on
Sunday evening saying that they were
trying to help the poor families in the
country by increasing subsidies to them
and that's why they had a decision to
make and that decision was made it
wasn't an easy one he said they had
three choices one was to increase taxes
across the board inside Iran the second
one was to increase the sale of oil that
was not going to happen because of US
sanctions at the moment on the Iranians
and the third was to increase the price
of fuel for Iranians and that's what
they decided to go with this decision
has had some very serious consequences
number of people have turned out across
the country to protest and show their
anger there have been two deaths
reported so far one of a policeman in
kermanshah City and another of the
protester in sarin Dodge
well Marvin Burundi is the Dean of the
Faculty of world studies at the
University of Tehran and he joins us now
nice of you to give us your time now
this of course was going to happen
anyway but the decision to hand on these
subsidies has been brought for
is that going to have an impact do you
think on the protest will it be enough
to placate that anger well that remains
to be seen I think that the problem was
that the government was slow to explain
what it was about to do I mean the
increasing the price is threefold was a
huge shock to everyone and it was quite
sudden that the government didn't
declare it beforehand and that scared a
lot of people in in theory and I think
in practice it's something that had to
be done because Iranian gasoline is is
sold at eight cents a liter which is
very low and a lot of Iranian oil gets
smuggled across the border into
neighboring countries we have 15
neighboring countries even countries in
the Persian Gulf they smuggle Iranian
gasoline so it's a big problem in the
country and also consumption has been
going up very rapidly and the Iranians
are also concerned that if they it goes
too high they'll become net importers
and Americans could use that as leverage
against the country so they did have to
increase the price of gasoline also
because the rich used subsidized
gasoline disproportionately much more
than those who are disenfranchised many
people don't have cars many people
travel every weekend to the north of the
country to their villa so it's not very
fair and this the government is planning
to take the money from the extra money
from the sales and give it to the 70% of
the Iranians who are of lower income so
theoretically is the right thing to do
but I think many people are very
critical of the way in which the
governments did it and many people are
afraid that it will it will harm them
and not everyone trusts the
administration partially because of the
fact that they've been pursuing liberal
liberal economic policies and poor
people are very become cynical when
these policies are pursued as you say
this has happened at a time when of
course is increasing inflation there's
been economic decline in any event set
against the sanctions that have been
reimpose over the nuclear deal and of
course there are going to be
mentoree elections in February is there
a concern here amongst the
administration that protests that begin
about one thing
in this case fuel hikes could also turn
to something greater and may also have
an impact on that election in February
yes I think President rouhani is taking
a big risk if these if this plan doesn't
turn out to work well for him it's going
he's going it's going to be reflected in
the elections I think it will be go very
badly for him but if the lower classes
in society hope those who are
disenfranchised in society do feel the
benefits in the next two three four
months and it could turn out to his
advantage so that remains to be seen at
the moment the government isn't
exceptionally popular because the
government did pursue the nuclear deal
and it it it put all its eggs in the
basket of the nuclear deal and that
didn't work out thanks to Trump so many
people are critical of the government
and again because of the liberal
economic policies that the government
was pursuing for the last few years
which has nothing to do with the nuclear
deal but another segment of society
became somewhat skeptical so President
rouhani at the moment according to polls
is not doing well but again this could
make things worse for him then again at
the moment it looks like he'll make
things worse but if in the next 2-3
months things do look better as a result
of this policy then it could change
things for the better for him what about
the immediate term with the the protest
and if the protests in fact continue
because we heard from the supreme leader
Ayatollah Ali Khamenei is saying that
hooligans are being carrying out these
attacks how do you think the the
response is going to be if the protest
indeed continued well I think there are
two sets of people that are that have
been on the streets many of those the
majority were protesters who didn't
carry out acts of violence but since
late last night or last evening we saw a
rapid increase in in in violence where
small groups in different towns and
cities and in parts of Tehran carried
out attacks on banks and even police
stations and unfortunately foreign meat
Persian language media which is funded
by Western governments and the Saudis
have been egging the rioters on and I
would have to point out that even the
BBC Persian and the VOA Persian they
have played a part in this but which is
which is I think in the long run it
hurts their own image because people see
how they are trying to you know create
division and sedition so they're hurting
themselves in the long run but most of
the protesters have not been violent by
any means they were critical of this
this policy they were out on the streets
the the numbers have died down today but
it's still 947 Tehran time so we'll have
to see what happens later tonight the
violence is also decreased tonight but
again we have to see what happens later
this evening but the majority of the
protesters were not violent the violence
was carried out by small groups that
seem to have been influenced from abroad
and also let's say the underworld today
to have been involved in some of these
attacks on on because some of the
targets like banks there these attacks
were carried out progress reasons
Mohammed Rodney thank you saying that
much for ruff for giving us your time